[Musique]
ling Jet Team c'est la première et seule
patrouille acrobatique privée civile au
monde volant sur
jet nous avons effectué une tournée dans
les pays
méditerranéens
Dijon split split athè athè Istanbul
istanbulam
tavar ch
be
B une contre la
[Musique]
mon
mécanicien c'est une aventure technique
h avions si on a la moindre panne qui
nous coince ça devient un peu
catastrophique C extraordinaire ça n'a
jamais été fait avant une aventure
aéronautique et humaine
[Musique]
extraordinaire encore une chose
unique
[Musique]
brling team c'est la la première et
seule patrouille acrobatique privé
civile au monde volant sur jet qui est
comparable à celui des patrouilles
acrobatiques nationales et ça il y a pas
l'équivalent nulle part dans le monde le
but c'est donner un spectacle et
provoquer des émotions au spectateurs et
pour ça on utilise toutes les ficelles
du spectacle aérien c'est une vraie
chorégraphie on enchaîne des figures en
patrouille serré où les avions sont
assez proches les uns des autres on est
quelquefois à 3 m ça demande extrêmement
de préparation d'entraînement pour
donner une illusion de de de
facilité c'est beaucoup d'émotions mêlé
et allié à de la précision et évidemment
du professionnalisme ça reste une
activité aéronautique donc on n pas le
droit à l'erreur et le but c'est de
concilier tout ça et de faire quelque
chose qui plaise en
transmettant des images fantastiques
inoubliables et faire découvrir au au
spectateurs des choses qu'ils ont jamais
vu
ailleurs l'avion que nous utilisons dans
le brathling Jet Team est le L39
albatrose c'est un avion d'entraînement
militaire de fabrication tchque qui a
été produit en très grand nombre à
l'époque où la guerre froide faisait que
les l'URSS donnait à ses amis à ses pays
amis un grand nombre d'avions de ce type
et puis bien après la chute du du mur de
Berlin et bien il s'est trouvé que ces
avions sont étent un petit peu orphelins
et n'avit plus d'utilité ils sont
purement civils entièrement
démilitarisés ils ne peuvent absolument
pas servir à autre chose qu'à faire du
spectacle désormais c'est très très rare
de pouvoir voler à titre civil sur ce
type d'avion là donc on a la chance de
pouvoir le faire pour notre notre
activité c'est un avion qui est parfait
avec des performances d'avion de chasse
il est très graphique dans le ciel il
est très fiable on trouve encore
beaucoup de pièces ça nous permet de
faire la maintenance et de voler en
toute sécurité l'avion est biplace ce
qui facilite grandement notre logistique
puisque de cette manière nous pouvons
nous déplacer avec nos mécaniciens je
pense qu'il y a une unanimité pour
reconnaître au L39 une harmonie dans
dans ses formes et un côté
esthétique
traditionnellement l'activité de
brathling Jet Team est en Europe on vole
à peu près tous les ans dans une dizaine
de pays on fait une cinquantaine de
démonstration et ça fait plusieurs
années que nous sommes appelés à faire
des démonstrations également soit au
Moyen-Orient à Abu Dhabi soit aux îles
du Cap Vert dans différents endroits
nous avons effectué une tournée dans les
pays méditerranéens et ce dans une une
période de très très dense de 15 jours
qu' voyage compris et et démonstration
compris nous avons voyager avec 8 L39 7
pour faire des démonstrations plus un
avion qui servait d'avion de réserve et
puis nous avons également emmené un
avion de soutien c'est la première fois
que nous nous déplacions à neu avions
pour une vingtaine de personnes au total
c'est d'abord un défi humain avec H
pilotes h mécaniciens notre vie a réglé
sur le rythme du groupe donc c'est le
premier challenge il y a une dimension
diplomatique les pays qui entretiennent
de très bonnes relations avec le avec la
France il y aura pas de difficultés
particulières à obtenir les les
autorisations mais pour des pays où
éventuellement les relations seraient un
petit peu moins faciles avec l'État
français éventuellement on pourrait ne
pas être les bienvenus ou avoir besoin
d'un petit peu plus d'explication sur la
raison exacte de notre déplacement avant
d'être accueilli de manière
satisfaisante ou le L39 est encore en
activité dans certaines dans certains
pays dans les forces armées lorsqu'on
apparaît sur un écran radar ou à la vue
des contrôleurs ou des militaires avec
plusieurs appareils ensemble ils font
tout de suite le rapprochement avec une
formation militaire ça c'est c'est
inéniable ça peut effectivement
expliquer la difficulté à obtenir des
autorisations de survol dans certains
pays il faut bien démontrer aux
autorités que ces avions sont devenus
civils sont exploités par une société
civile et ne représent absolument aucun
danger leur silhouette éta effectivement
la silhouette d'un avion de chasse mais
les peintures montrent bien qu'ils sont
entièrement pacifiques c'est une
aventure
technique voyager sur un long courrier
il est taillé pour faire de la route il
est taillé pour aller loin et pour voler
une dizaine d'heur de vol le L39 il est
complètement différent c'est un avion
qui a été conçu pour l'entraînement des
pilotes c'est-à-dire pour décoller voler
45 minutes aux alentours d'un aérodrome
et se reposer il est pas fait pour faire
de la navigation au long cours nous
sommes obligés tout de même de faire des
petites étapes de faire step by step il
y a un rendez-vous qui est donné aux
gens donc il faut être là à l'heure le
timing est très serré c'est un peu une
course contre la monte et il faut être
prêt à tout moment à prendre une
décision à laisser un avion quelque part
à prendre des décisions météo qui
peuvent être difficilees à prendre
d'annulation si on a la moindre panne
qui nous coince ça devient un peu
catastrophique c'est un gros travail on
part pas au au coup de sifflet bref
c'est
impossible quand on part pour un un raid
comme ça on arrive toujours tôt au levé
du jour il y a plein de choses
à préparer c'est un peu comme le cinéma
hurry up and wait tout le monde se
retrouve à Dijon toute la caravane s
Brou et se met en route tout le monde
est excité d'autant plus que ça
représenta beaucoup de travail tout le
monde a à cœur que ça que ça marche que
tout tout fonctionne bien et en même
temps la petite anxiété est-ce que on n
pas raté quelque chose à la préparation
est-ce qu'il va faire beau est-ce qu'on
a rien oublié est-ce que tout a été bien
préparé est-ce que les avions vont bien
marcher est-ce qu'il va pas avoir ce
petit grain de sable qui va faire que
pour moi une
responsabilité de partir mais aussi de
revenir avec tous les avions et tout
on est bien tendu jusqu'au décollage on
est assez tendu jusqu'à ce que on soit
sûr qu'il fasse beau et quand il fait
beau on a claqué la porte et on est
parti pour un long voyage et on est très
cont
35 bienvenue à tous on
[Musique]
ferme
[Applaudissements]
bonjour déber le roulage par
[Musique]
le devant
décollage tout le monde vole à peu près
à Cap sud-est direction split la
[Musique]
Croatie
on s'est retrouvé très rapidement sur le
Montblanc sur les ALP avec un joli
soleil c'est vrai que notre but c'était
bien d'aller trouver le
[Musique]
soleil la Pline DESP on passe pas très
loin une Venise et ensuite on va
descendre toute l'Adriatique en
direction de de
[Musique]
Split
on se pose après 2h de après 2h de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vol donc tout est parfait pour l'instant
aux escales bah les pilotes comme
d'habitude ils vont au bar draguer les
filles et et ce sont
les ce sont les mécaniciens qui
s'occupent des avions durant le convyage
le pilote fait son métier de pilote il
pilote il tient sa place fait sa radio
il suit sa navigation il fait en sorte
que l'avion arrive à bon port en toute
sécurité lorsque l'avion est posé le
mécanicien lui descend et c'est à son
tour de s'occuper de l'avion de faire
son travail de manière à ce que tout
soit fait pour que l'avion redécolle en
toute sécurité chacun son rôle mais en
fait tout le monde est complémentaire
c'est équipage le but des étapes c'est
toujours de remettre du pétrole dans les
avions nous mettons on environ 2000 l de
kérosène dans chaque avion ça nécessite
à peu près 2h et dem de remise en
œuvre 14h30 sur l'aéroport de Split
contrairement à ce que vous pouvez
penser nous ne sommes pas en train de
faire la sieste même si ça fait 30
minutes que nous sommes assis dans nos
avions c'est simplement parce qu'il y a
un retard de contrôle aérien et on
attend l'autorisation de mettre en route
et de partir sur athè normalement on en
a encore pour 30 minutes donc ça fera
une sieste relativement prolongée mais
bon l'Ance c'est
[Musique]
d'arriver nous avions déposé un plan de
vol accepté mais il a été délayé quand
on envoie un plan de vol que ce soit
depuis Dijon ou depuis split il est
traité à mastrich imposé comme ça en
cours de journée peuvent finir
effectivement par décaler la totalité
des vols et provoquer une arrivée de
nuit à la dernière étape ce que on
souhaite éviter le plus
[Musique]
possible cap sud-est pour survoler en
gros l'Albanie et rentrer sur le
territoire grec donc pour aller à
[Musique]
Athène
sur le trajet du côté de l'Albanie on a
rencontré un tuname monstrueux un nuage
d'orage c'est un cumulus qui s'est
développé verticalement de manière très
importante faut éviter de rentrer dedans
parce qu'on va subir de très très fortes
turbulences c'est une énorme cheminée
donc c'est un énorme ventilateur dans le
sens verticale il y a de la pluie de la
grê en givre il peut y avoir de la
foudre trou d'air très fort turbulance
c'est enage trs très
[Musique]
dangereux sur toute la région de
l'oslavie de chy sur
conflitpp de bon de moins bon
moment
[Musique]
première étape importante arrivée en
Grèce première étape de cette tournée
la base aérienne de lf6 base aérienne de
l'armée de l'air grec où il y a plein
d'avion de transport plein de choses le
port du Piré était en finale tout à
l'heure quand on s'est posé on a
vraiment l'impression d'arriver en Grèce
donc on espère faire du bon
[Musique]
travail et ben notre métier nous donne
la chance de faire volô
spéciaux on a réussi de voler en
formation serrée à H avions au-dessus de
l'Acropole déjà normalement on n pas le
droit de survoler les villes en basse
altitude avec des avions surtout des
jets mais là on nous a demandé de le
faire c'était le 75e anniversaire de
l'Armée de l'Air grecque 2000 an avant
il y avait de Zeus qui mangeait du
raisin couché sur un sofa faut quand
même bien bien bienre conscient de ça et
on nous paye pour survoler la chambre de
Zeus c'est quand même fantastique quoi
des milliers de pilotes dans le dans le
monde doivent nous envier c'est un réel
privilège pour une patrouille civile
aller survoler un centre-ville comme ça
c'est çaarrive
[Musique]
jamais nous avions pris des des des
passagers de l'Armée de l'Air grec dans
nos avions pour leur faire plaisir et
les remercier de de leur accueil ce
genre de vol est exceptionnel eux-mêm
Ava jamais
[Musique]
fait
le lendemain jour de démonstration à
athèn bord de mer au sud de la ville un
site magnifique face à la mer très
belles installations pour le
public on est en aver on fumé ene grand
de FL on y manque de chance dans ces
pays où tout le monde part en vacances
pour trouver le soleil on est tombé sur
un jour où c'était un peu mitigé un
petit peu de vent plafond bas plus on
attendait et plus le temps se dégradait
avec l'impossibilité éventuel de faire
le spectacle quand la patrouille arrive
sur zone ils n'ont pas le plafond pour
effectuer la démonstration complète et
donc la première démonstration de la
tournée c'est la démonstration
intermédiaire le Rolling show pas de
plan vertical pur
[Musique]
3 jours de pluie par an en Grèce à athèn
et c'est fait pour nous
[Musique]
tu penses à tout tout le travail qui été
fait pour
organiser cette démo en
[Musique]
Grèce la ruche se remet en branle donc
tout le monde travaille à préparer le
vol
suivant le temps est mauvais de plus en
plus mauvais pour partir sur la Turquie
sur Istanbul
on prend le même chemin que les trois
potes uliss achile et Agamemnon lorsque
cette d'héline femme d'Agamemnon
s tiré avec Hector le fils de Priam donc
roi de TR quand ils sont partis avec
leur bateau fout sur la gueule à Priam
et Hector à TR quoi voilà le souci était
déjà là dès le matin pour la
démonstration mais également pour le vol
de mise en place sur istanbou après et
on verra que on avait raison de se faire
du
[Musique]
souci
le système de contrôle aérien à athèn
avait sauté ils étaient incapablebles de
traiter nos plans de vol donc on a
décidé de partir à Istanbul à vue on
quitte la Grèce on traverse la mer Égée
très vite quand on a passer la frontière
turque et bien on a dû monter tous les
avions dans les nuages pour pouvoir
continuer à
[Musique]
progresser
leure tournait la nuit commençait à
tomber il est quand même plus difficile
d'arriver à avions en formation de nuit
que de jour nous allions nous poser à
Istanbul avec des pointes horaires de
trafic qui rendent l'intégration d'une
patrouille plus
délicate on a réussi au bout d'un moment
à contacter
le centre de contrôle d'Istanbul tous
les avions de Lig la on est parti en
basse altitude donc on consommait plus
et arriv à istanbou ils nous ont fait
attendre fait comprendre contrô rien que
ce serait bien que on se pose rapidement
quoi ce qu'ils n'ont peut-être pas
compris c'est qu'on était h avions et
qu'on ne pose pas h avions en même temps
sur une
piste finalement on nous
autorise
en fait ils nous ont laissé nous
débrouiller ce qui est toujours la
meilleure solution on a réussi à poser
les avions et là on était content de se
dire bon on est posé et arrivera ce qui
arrivera mais au moins on est là on est
posé
[Musique]
on arrive à Istanbul on s'imagine qu' va
faire 25 degr qui va une tempête de ciel
bleu à la vue de la météo on a déjà une
bonne idée de ce qui va se passer il y a
pied de plafond il y a pas mal de pluie
il y a beaucoup de vent donc il dit
beaucoup de vent dit beaucoup de
turbulence cela dit on n jamais à l'abri
d'un bon coup et peut très bien avoir
une éclairci qui intervient à la
dernière
minute il faut prévoir tous les
scénarios c'est-à-dire aussi bien le
meilleur que le
pire le scénario le plus probable quand
on voyait le temps qu'il faisait dehors
c'était effectivement de faire un
programme
minimum en coordination avec les
organisateurs de l'événement sur place
nous avons envisagé tous les cas
possibles jusqu'à
l'annulation il y a une seule
démonstration possible en Turquie donc
nous n'avons pas de de deuxième chance
c'est ma responsabilité de décider si on
y va ou si on y va pas je dois m'assurer
aussi que tout le monde est confortable
avec ma décision on a à cœur également
de rendre à nos autres la gentillesse
qu'il nous apportent en nous accueillant
mais il y a une limite et dire non pour
nous c'est un déchirement on est aux
avions pr à mettre en route à 20 on
n'aura pas 2500 pieds 3500 pieds pour
pour tirer top top et pu toi tu parles
en même temps récte la fumée top ça veut
dire que c'est
des
[Musique]
conneries donc moment le leader d'école
en disant bien tant pis on va faire un
un show à plat le flat show et on pourra
pas donner mieux mais il faut absolument
donner quelque chose à ce public qui
attend qui est venu là pour voir le
brightling Jet
Team
nous n'étions pas seul dans la
zone c'est très difficile de tenir en
place il y a beaucoup de
turbulence au lieu d'être à 2 M50 on va
se mettre à 3 m
[Musique]
3,50
[Applaudissements]
c'était un vol très tendu très
inconfortable vraiment difficile
peut-être on est plus dur que l'on est
fait on s'est bien battu ouais istanbou
c'était vraiment la guerre on avait
qu'une seule option c'est celle qu'on a
choisi il faut avoir la sagesse de
s'arrêter au bon moment je pense qu'on
l' fait comme il
fallait le lendemain on se lève très tôt
parce que ça va être une journée
compliquée la fluidité de cette journée
quelque chose d'important donc comme ça
doit être fluide ça ne le sera
[Musique]
pas
7h2 il fait pas beau il fait froid même
endroit qu' 24 he situation est
mer displ pour alleristbou àav
faitaman traverser une couche nuageuse
on sait pas trop les blessur qu'elle
fait en de box de décollage prévu dans
minutes quelle heure est le train
là pour prendre une douche c'est pas
[Musique]
sympa mais là surprise un avillon a une
fuite carburant sous un réservoir
[Musique]
largable les mécan TR de
regarder le déroulement chronologique de
la journée tel qu'il était prévu est
déjà
ruigné
on met en route bientôt et on n va aller
au
[Musique]
soleil
là on commence à tout
recalculer c'est l'étape un petit peu
particulière Turquie Israël pour rentrer
sur le territoire israélien on doit
d'abord les contacter au téléphone avant
de décoller leur reconfirmer notre nom
ja botelin le code àire notre nom ch
Sierra yankke Lima Sierra et répondre à
une question particulière où la réponse
était préparée et la réponse connue de
leur service Gaston ça rajoute un petit
peu de tension dans la mesure où si les
procédures d'authentification sont mal
exécuté et bien l'entrée dans l'espace
aérien sera refusée on a prévu de partir
à 8 de Dalaman pour faire le volet 8
vers tavive et là 2 minutes avant le
décollage en fait la tour de contrôle
nous annonce qu'on n pas autorisé à
décoller à 8 on doit décoller un par
[Musique]
un
là ça remet complètement en question nos
plans notre vision des choses parce que
normalement on a tout prévu la mise en
route le pétrole la navigation et
l'arrivée à Israël en formation et là
refus
moralité on est obligé de partir de
façon
individuelle et surprise problème de
mise en route sur mon
avion est-ce qu'on laisse
l'avion est- qu'on ESS de réparer pour
loin avec le risque de bloquer l'avion
plus loin jusqu'à ce que finalement mon
avion décide de mettre en route
[Musique]
normalementl
ALP
[Musique]
ilito derrière
moi écoute je penseil avait sa
c
[Musique]
quand on va dans un pays qu'on a jamais
survolé avec des procédures
d'authentification un peu particulière
c'est toujours c'est toujours
intéressant pour un pilote c'est quelque
chose se poser en Israël au commande de
son propre avion a vive ses meetings
pour un pilote de chasse c'est la guerre
des 6 jours c'est c'est le mirage 3
c'est mes premières lectures de Tangui
et la verdure ou mirage sur l'Orient
c'est c'est des mirages à TelAviv c'est
tout ça ça m'a vraiment rappelé une
image de cette bande dessinée où on voit
les mirages de Tang laavure voler
justement devant t la vive sur sur ce
front de mer c'est ça et sauf qu'on est
dans
l'avion
[Musique]
c'était la première fois qu'il y avait
une démonstration sur la plage de
taville c'est la trè de ce périple et
c'est seulement la première
démonstration que je qualifierai de
normal l'aéroport international de
téaviv fermé puisque le lieu de la
démonstration c'est le bord de plage
dans l'axe des pistes de l'aérodrome
international de
benouron je suis là je fais ça ça
s inro
les chiens sont lâchés la météo est
splendide les fumées claquent dans le
ciel bleu c'est magnifique et c'est
[Musique]
parti
[Applaudissements]
l'autorisation de venir à TelAviv de s'y
poser de faire une démonstration est
quelque chose de tout à fait
exceptionnel de téaviv nous partons à
Luxembourg Luxembourg c'est le nom de
code de Beyrouth parce que on ne peut
pas dire à té Aviv qu'on part à Beyrouth
et quand on est à Beyrou on ne peut pas
dire qu'on vient de téaviv donc on vient
de Luxembourg les relations entre Israël
et le Liban sont tells que les vols
directs d'Israël vers le Liban sont
interdits on doit passer par Chypre avec
un atterrissage à l'arnaka pour faire
une escale sauver les apparences et ne
pas être supposé venir de té Aviv c'est
une grande hypocrisie parce qu'en fait
tout le monde sait très bien d'où on
vient et on repartira mais il faut pas
le dire ça nous rallonge un petit peu on
fait un bon crochet de 2 heures
supplémentaires et ensuite directement
l'
[Musique]
beyutth beyroutth beyoutth beyouth dans
les images d'Épinal c'est la guerre du
Liban c'est un endroit très compliqué
pour nous c'était une
première berou c'est une ville dont on a
tellement entendu parler à travers les
conflits qu'on ne sait pas si on aura
l'impression d'être les bienvenus si
c'est une une ville chantier ou ou ou ou
une ville qui qui
[Musique]
revit
l'arrivée sur Beyrouth et le break sur
l'aéroport est quelque chose
[Musique]
d'étonnant je n'imaginais pas un jour me
poser à Beyrouth
[Musique]
et en fait et bien on a un superbe
accueil comme
partout à chaque étape on va faire un
vol pour emmener les médias sur des
sites exceptionnels et là on a survolé
le nordliban on a été vers la plaine de
la Béa pour ensuite aller réaliser
quelques figures au-dessus de la forêt
de cèdre symbole du Liban
[Musique]
la PL de la béc la frontière à cassirie
c'est était un endroit souvenez-vous il
y a 20 ans ou 25 ans où la guerre a été
terrible entre chiit et chrétiens voilà
quoi c'est chargé
d'histoire d'histoire d'histoire
difficile
quoi alors la forêt de cèdre c'est une
toute petite forêt qui est minuscule qui
va faire peut-être 500 m 500 m de
diamètre un petit peu
circulaire de voir au loin la Sye et de
voir au nord la Turquie de deviner
Israël au
[Musique]
sud
aboute je crois que nous sommes une des
premières patrouilles acrobatiques à
s'être jamais
produite et nous avons le privilège
d'avoir l'aéroport international qui est
fermé pour nous pendant 45 minutes pour
pouvoir faire notre
démonstration me dit le commandant
d'aérodrome la dernière fois qu'on l'a
fermé c'est parce qu'on était envahi
donc ça nous fait plaisir que ce soit
pour des raisons un peu plus pacifistes
grande fierté de voler pour ces gensl on
met en route on est à 100 m2 on décolle
de la piste qui situe à quelques
centaines de mètres donc ils ont
vraiment le spectacle en direct live
[Musique]
à
droite
gauche rverse à
droite C et ça tourne on y va boule
Avenger
[Musique]
gauche
éclatement stop stop
[Musique]
stop on a eu un message d'un habitant
qui nous a dit bah c'est quand même
sympa de voir passer des avions audessus
de notre tête et qui nous bombarde pas
mais bon dans un pays qui n'est pas
toujours perçu comme il devrait l'être
qui est toujours dans des situations de
conflit le fait que des gens de
l'extérieur apportent quelque chose et
leur offrent quelque chose est quelque
chose de fortement
ressenti le lendemain nouveau départ de
la caravane pour la Jordanie ou encore
une fois compte tenu du contexte le
survol direct en provenance de beyouth
de l'espace aérien israélien que nous
devions traverser pour aller en Jordanie
nous était interdit comment obtenir
l'autorisation de survoler Israël
certainement pas en partant du Liban ça
c'est proscrit avec les contacts que
nous avons eu de jours avant nous
arrivons à négocier de nouveau un
atterrissage à
[Musique]
l'arnaka et puis ensuite direction la
Jordanie on survole Israël ce qui est
exceptionnel parce que normalement on ne
survole pas Israël on se pose en Israël
mais on n pas le droit et c'est
simplement parce que nous sommes donc
donc connu par notre passage de jours
avant nous obtenons cette autorisation
et le contrôle aérien commençait à être
habitué à nous voir traverser la zone de
droite et de gauche donc ça s'est passé
d'une manière très
fluide passe audessus de Jérusalem
au-dessus de la mer Morte et on arrive
ensuite de l'autre côté sur sur
Aman en plein cœur de la Jordanie c'est
vraiment désertique et on voit appître
Aman donc une ville comme on peut
s'imaginer grande en plein milieu du
désert un petit peu de tempête de sable
pas une énorme
visie la ville a la couleur du désert on
narrive pas bien à distinguer les
contours de la ville l'arrivée àan est
quelque chose effectivement d'assez
impressionnant parce que la piste est
perdue en plein milieu de la
ville me avec en train de donner des
res
[Musique]
qui c'est qui a touché mon pneu qui
c'est qui a touché mon pneu
[Musique]
là ça va c'est pas trop
dur écoute ça fait qu qure avions qu'on
pousse là que tu quoi je
éatoire CELI personne n'a rien
[Musique]
vu le lendemain de notre arrivée nous
avons fait un vol absolument
exceptionnel nous décollons damane pour
aller survoler les ruine d'un château
templier et ensuite redescendre la
vallée du Jourdain en direction de la
mer
[Musique]
morte au bout de la vallée du jordin
mais la Mer Morte
[Musique]
la Mer Morte c'est la Bible c'est le
berceau de notre culture ça a une valeur
inestimable et puis en bas de boucle on
est sous le niveau de la mer donc on est
sous terre notre altimè nous est calé
sur le zéro moyen de la mer et là en
fait on arrive à voler avec un altimè
qui est en dessous de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
zéro
[Musique]
tourner des boucles au-dessus de la mer
morte avec des avions réaction c'est
quelque chose que Personne n'avait fait
[Musique]
avant
dernière démo un peu plus de
stress on a conscience d'être à la fin
d'une aventure on aura pu voler partout
c'était prévu donc on y est c'est la
dernière pourvu qu'un avion tombe pas en
panne à la mise en route pour que tout
se passe
bien c'est la dernière il faut que ça
marche il faut que il faut qu'on la
fasse il faut qu'elle soit
belle nous avions à Haman les deux
ingrédients pour nous compliquer un peu
la tâche une température plus élevée que
d'habitude et puis un terrain qui est
aux alentour de 2000 pieds des
performances légèrement dégradé les
performances de l'avion sont àoindri au
niveau poussé donc on on est obligé de
d'aller chercher les vitesses les
volumes sont un petit peu plus
importants
il y avait des personnes de la famille
royale qui étaient présentes un très bon
accueil de la part de l'Armée de l'Air
jordanienne comme on pouvait
l'imaginer la patrouille jordanienne
vole en premier on les croise
régulièrement sur le circuit
européen
à notre tour de de nous élancer dans le
dans le ciel de
[Musique]
amanuch
et
[Musique]
tourne
on y
va
et et ça
tourne g
éclat St stop stop
[Musique]
t c'était la dernière de cette tournée
au MoyenOrient c'était la dernière de la
saison et pour nous une fin de saison
c'est toujours important pour moi
c'était particulier parce que c'était la
dernière de ma 30e année comme leader de
[Musique]
patrouille la démonstration est terminée
on plie les décors et on
repart le lendemain on se lève tt pour
reprendre le cap au nord NordOuest Dion
c'est loin c'est dans 2
jours la ruche s'ébroue à nouveau pour
le départ et le retour vers Dijon en
plusieurs
[Musique]
étapes on fait directement Jordanie
d'Aman
[Musique]
la pression ne se relâche pas pendant
qu' voyage retour parce que les
problématiques techniqu aéronautiqu
restent présente je n'en veux pour
preuve que l'arrivée à Dalaman où le
contrôleur a fait une erreur s'est
trompé d'interprétation de notre radar
nous a donné un cap et heureusement
qu'il faisait beau parce que sinon il
nous mettait dans la montagne et ensuite
on fait Dalaman
[Musique]
athè
lendemain et ben ça va être la
destination finale finale donc on
revient
Dijon on fait les mêmes étapes on se
pose split pour refûer un petit peu et
puis de Split et ben on redécolle et
direction
Dijon on arrive au break à Dijon les
avions se posent on arrive un à un au
parking un à un les les moteurs des
avions se coupe et quand le dernier
moteur s'arrête il a une espèce de
sensation de de vide de fin de quelque
chose
qui est à la fois le plaisir d'être
arrivé d'être rentré d'avoir ramené tous
les hommes et tous les avions à bon port
et puis bah déjà une nostalgie se dire
bah demain on volera
pas on est content de rentrer et
excitation d'avoir réussi quelque chose
d'avoir rempli de mission et tout ça
avec un groupe d'hommes on a quand même
vécu quelque chose d'extraordinaire je
dire on on a survolé des territoires
qu'on avait jamais survolé avant on a
fait des choses que très peu de gens au
monde auront l'opportunité la chance de
faire donc on est à la fois triste de de
que ça se termine et puis super content
d'avoir fait ce qu'on a fait
on a rencontré des gens de culture de
religion d'origine complètement
différente et on a cette constance dans
dans la gentillesse dans l'amitié dans
la qualité de
l'échange on a côtoyer des gens très
différents des gens que malheureusement
la politique oppose et qui en fait sont
tous des gens
extraordinaires je le fais
demain et la première question qu'on se
pose c'est bon quand
pouretard on demande qui a
[Musique]
recommencer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
I